mario mio dio ciao ciao
che bello vederti va da quanto tempo ma
lasci il tuo numero così ce ne vollero
un caffè insieme che ci raccontiamo un
po di ultime news che è bello vedermi
che è bello vedermi ma se non ci
sopportiamo dalla seconda media che ci
vediamo ma che stai dicendo
ma quanto sei falsa e poi il caffè tra
cui prende pure da solo che ci vogliano
il caffè con te ma sai che proprio
l'altro giorno ti stavo pensando e tua
chissà che fine ha fatto 8 certo se
sistemi 349 mari sono ormai settimane
che ci penso io non posso più esserti
amico io provo qualcosa per te voglio
voglio condividere la quotidianità fare
nuove esperienze voglio magari un giorno
anche avere una famiglia
devo saperlo tu cosa provi per me
immaginavo che sarebbe arrivato questo
momento per te
edo provo tanta pena tantissima non mi
piace non mi sei mai piaciuto e mani
piacerai e do io non vorrei ferire i
tuoi sentimenti ma per me la nostra
amicizia è la cosa più importante almeno
per il momento preferirei insomma non
cambiare le cose tra di noi
poi un giorno bene mai dire mai
non si può mai sapere nella vita anno ma
sei sicura che mi sta bene non mi fa un
po grassa lo vedo un po pacchiano su di
me si tifa grassa e si e pacchiano ma
siamo in ritardo
se io ti dico che questo sistema che sta
bene invece per altre due ore per
scegliere un altro oppure vi dirà che
non viene più e io a ballare da solo non
ci vado quindi a non lo stai scherzando
se pazzesca certo volo da o è presentato
c'è gabbana uguali
mario non so più quello che provo penso
che ci serve del tempo per capire quello
che vogliamo quello di cui abbiamo
bisogno
ci serve una pausa tu cosa ne pensi
cosa ne penso
io penso che tu abbia un'altra essi non
la conta giusta cos'è questa storia
della pausa ma da quando ma una pausa
per cosa poi una pausa è soltanto una
scusa per lasciarsi a rate non scappi e
non mi lasci così no mi dispiace
tu sei mio e tuo padre sulla parte che
la famosa non lo vogliono ben accetto
sì sì la la penso come te sono d'accordo
ma ragiona non dirmi che ti piace
successo
no non mi piace io lo amo pazzamente lui
è tutta la mia vita io lo sogna la notte
in sveglia al mattino ero penso io
voglio sposare qui sarà mio
un giorno saranno ovviamente no ti pare
allora vorrei come la cina coi miei cioè
non resta una serata pazzesca e ti
piaciuto la rosa il papa ei complimenti
della mamma sincera e stata una serata
di merda
tua mamma mi sta sulle palle la vecchia
pia continua a parlare della tua ex
elogiando roma che sembra il caso
veramente di cattivo gusto
dopo poi non sa cucinare e quell'altro
faceva schifo e non ho mangiato tutto
perché mi piace chiamate a carte
guardavate che il mini il natale io l'ho
buttato nel cammino sincera e stata la
serata più bella della mia vita ora i
tuoi sono veramente fantastici mi hanno
fatto veramente sentire a casa
cioè non sono mai sentita a disagio per
tutta la cena poi la crosta l'arrosto
cosa non era guarda luca cosa mi ha
appena scritto quanto è tenero è o non è
il ragazzo perfetto
beh se con perfetti intendi che ti fa le
corna con tutta la scuola si è perfetto
a e per la cronaca ci ha provato anche
con me
meglio single che cornute temo che
carino che tenero avercelo un ragazzo
così conto ti invidio anche se vi ho
detto di preparare per oggi pascoli
montale ungaretti
stamattina mi sono svegliato con una
volta di non sentire qualcosa su
leopardi quindi mi pare di dopare e te
pareva
ho studiato tutto tranne leopardi che
vivono mi chiede adesso come faccio
facciamo una cosa se questo video arriva
60.000 like girerò la seconda parte è
ripasserò leopardi e mi raccomando
iscrivetevi al canale cliccate sulla
campanella che trovate vicino a caso
l'iscrizione non dimenticate però è
soprattutto seguito visto tutti gli
altri soci
instagram facebook e tic toc adesso
probabilmente armi qualcosa e giacomo
leopardi
sì allora
[Musica]